mas sou a sexualidade é sempre um
desafio porque imaginando que estava
desaparecido não é verdade
é desafio para quem ouve mas também um
desafio para quem vai nunca sabemos como
é que vão reagir às pessoas que de fato
temos na frente
a palestra será sexualidade ponto
falta criatividade é que o que mais
motiva a vida e que na sexualidade é
extremamente importante todos nós
sabemos o que é novidade estimulamos nós
sabemos que o facto da paixão é que mais
nos motiva para a sexualidade mas vamos
pensar um bocadinho porque que a paixão
que estar apaixonados
nós tivemos hoje em dia com as novas
tecnologias que estamos a tudo mas já
vamos sair três áreas pensamos primeiro
o nosso em fato estar apaixonados mas a
paixão é um processo obsessivo com uma
loucura estamos focados na pessoa porque
estamos apaixonados que é muito melhor
muitas vezes está no parque de
estacionamento com essa pessoa sou coxa
esquerda e faz com outra música
o estímulo é muito maior por isso uma
das coisas que nós temos que pensar aqui
é como uma relação a dois
as empurra gosta mais e outro que gosta
menos gosta mais do fato o gosta mais de
fato é que eu que os cravos a relação ou
seja é que o que tem mais prazer mas é
mais controlado porto que é o principal
quem diga que falta paixão é como uma
droga não é
eu tô divulgado por aquela pessoa aquela
pessoa com vá o meu próprio estímulo
para viver a vida e outro é o fim do ano
eu posso ir daqui há qualquer lá à
procura de facto estilo e sexualidade em
geral é o futuro da nossa espécie
dependa do fato do sexo
a maior parte de nós somos feitos e
produtos sexos já nem todos por quem
tenha baixo 30 anos já pode ser fruto de
sol medicamente assistida e dá algum
laboratório no bairro mas a grande
mudança na sexualidade surgiu quando há
50 anos e com que roupa de cimento da
pílula
hoje em dia nós podemos ter c
sem gravidez e greve de sexo tudo mudou
nessa altura hetero antes das redes
sociais por isso é 1957 nos anos 60
surgido aos a nova dose as minhas chavão
que o fato era grande mas se passam e é
uma igualdade igualdade a subida na
audição mulher e é um homem hormonais
viela iguais
um dos dois tempos e um dos dois está
doente nós somos diferentes e eu como
sou médica quando as duas análises
iguais a tribunais fituri o padre tem
tratado uma das pessoas pois na
sexualidade é igual é é sexualidade não
é só as monas mas são fundamentais já
vamos ver
e é isso que nos vai muitas vezes
motivada é fechar tudo lava nato ea
correr atrás de alguém mas como em tudo
não há só vê benefícios e não há só
coisas positivas
cris é pílula foi muito boa mas teve um
sinal teve um sinal negativo
principalmente para as mulheres que é ep
é uma nova vitória ou seja diminui o
hyper mesmo a ovulação e diminuir a
libido das mulheres são como os animais
na fase da votação quando vamos temos a
dívida aumentava sociedade em que
vivemos com disfunção vida que nós temos
hoje em dia nem de poucas horas andamos
cansados precisamos de energia para
fazer a moça se às zonas não devem mais
linha muitas vezes não funciona
por isso engravidamos mas o desejo
muitas vezes diminuiu em muitas vezes
não é vã partilhado com lucas aula
porque a sexualidade do homem não é
igual à da minha emoção somas já notou
iguaizinhos só que ela e qual foi devido
à mudança de fato nos homens
foi principalmente em 1998 com o
padecimento viagra que nós mulheres
achavam fantástico
vamos ter o mais velhinhos mexendo
funcionais não é bem assim porque a
sexualidade e suas plantas set foi mais
ou menos a mesma idade há aqui uma
discrepância eu toquei que acontecia e
víamos com os homens de fato
tem aqui um problema relações minha
sofreu executou um dom uma mulher a ser
um homem mas enganou se tinha havido o
que é ir e são dos homens viça e depois
contou muito estressados desliga se não
sabe onde está o interruptor enquanto as
mulheres é um canal é minhas podem
funcionar sempre só custeia com saber
que o costume dizer muitas vezes uma
coisa que é um campo em polêmica mas que
é real diz o ginecologista ea minha
consulta no dia a dia com uma
percentagem das mulheres chegou ao
consultório estou muito preocupada eu
gosto do meu marido tem uma boa relação
uma parceria ótimo mas eu não voltei a
ter relações de fato nós gosta ter
relações mas todos adoramos fazer amor
embora todos nós diz enquanto temos
relações não é infelizmente mas o sonho
em fato que é fazermos amor que o digo
muitas vezes só custeia com sabe nos
pode fazer amor depois das 22 horas é
impossível se nos levantamos as cheias
da manhã
não é assim que chegamos à casa fazemos
amor 24 24 e depois comemos
tranquilamente mas o que está aqui a
passar também em termos bastante
complicados e crescido mudou e usou
muito mudou primeiro com vimos com o
aparecimento da pílula dos anovulatórios
com o aparecimento do viagra e do time
las para manter a idéia é saltar também
bisou mas em excesso analisada e não vou
pois há cerca de 20 anos com as redes
sociais
mas qual é o grande impacto que temos
aqui das redes sociais é positivo e
negativo mas não estamos a ver cada vez
mais toma tentava os antidepressivos
então aumentado os ansiolíticos web
assim nós não temos checos queremos
sexualidade e por isso queremos assim
chinês queremos tudo mas a comunicação
social tem tido um aspecto importante
por um lado mas por outro lado - eu vou
usar aqui só um exemplo
vou contar uma historinha que eram 2018
anos
uma miúda perguntou me o que faz bem no
dia da criança que foi agora né ea mil
deles havia ocorrido uma barbie e ela
perguntou e toyo ito e humilde o pessoal
eu vou pedir um tampax ou tampax a
'disputa' parte saias eram da tua visão
pode ir à praia todos os dias possa
andar a cavalo ou possa andar de
bicicleta e ninguém sabia é já visto que
é por isso muitas vezes a informação não
é passada corretamente nem todos os
objetivos são cumpridos pelo matic pela
publicidade
isso é um aspecto extremamente
importante também no nosso dia a dia o
outro é tentarmos perceber o que fará
passa na sexualidade pelas diferentes
fatos todos nós somos ensinados a
subsídio mas me ensinado a fazer amor de
tentativa e erro
qual é o principal problema das
adolescentes na sexualidade quando
chegam ao consultório não consegue
atingir o orgasmo porque tem técnica
o clitóris não é só que o tal zinho eo
toucinho e tem uma pele lisinha por cima
que é um papo se como os homens tendo
pênis só que as minhas não são ensinadas
a tracionar navio tinha se com algumas
técnicas e até conseguem mastigar
mas o orgasmo é essencialmente
clitoriano quando as suas pensam muitas
vezes a e o mtur com beijinhos e tal
chegou à garagem seleccionou as pernas
depois há outros fatores aqui que as
pessoas acham que a vagina é um tubo e
tem odor desagradável e então vamos
baseado e fica se colocar de saliva
também só depois a idade certa ela quer
supermulher na esposa doméstica que é
difícil eleger aumentam a dívida está
diminuída e o que aqui temos de fazer é
calculado em fazer amor era e temos
programada um bocadinho tirada por
dissidentes e defar teve um bom horário
para fazer amor
depois criatividade é criatividade é
fundamental e não é só ter a vez das
redes sociais da internet de maneira
nenhuma eu possa durar mix com batatas
fritas mas não posso comer todos os dias
a mesma coisa
ora nós estamos preocupados e vamos a
todos diz o jantar de ramos sexualidade
também eu tentei umas ementas sexuais e
o tempo reduzido e nós tivemos muitas
vezes que ela já tinha chegam a casa já
depois da menopausa e se voltou
invisível uma nem dá por ela com o
vocábulo irão
olha não existirá racha tec acima
enquanto até o umbigo de maneira nenhuma
o código s1 como diria aquela
profissional e wilson ou coisa assim não
é permitida e foi apanhar alan giro em
cima da caverna em qualquer lado
espanhol nem todo lá nos mas maneira que
se torne visível passar o tempo eu
começar a ver o que o doutor eu tô
invisível
de fato houve um estímulo e como é que
só aumentar a libido das mulheres os
homens hoje em dia disse amar com
consulta para saber como é que aumentou
de vida das mulheres
nós desejamos o que não temos o desejo
ea camisola enquanto não tenho ainda
pois temos que as telas do roupa e não
quer dizer que uma pessoa esqueça do
marido nem dupla de saída mas quer dizer
é que o estímulo inicial muitas vezes
desaparece não fazer é tinha em casa 5 a
medida pode sair talvez desistimos em
casa a pessoa acha que a fazer amanhã
por isso tinha na rua e ninguém acha que
vai fazer uma roupa saio triste é a
afetividade e do fato o objetivo é que
sempre em casamento cada bonzinho e
tolerante mas nem tocar horas nem as
caixas que os homens no tempo eliminados
mas nós sabemos que os bebedores da bola
na véspera não deve fazer da moda porque
se tiverem o kit testosterona ao e sons
todos nunca nós não queremos um todo em
casa nem mundial pôde se aprender alguma
coisa com a globalização e com as redes
sociais sempre o que buscamos feias
alguma coisa primeiro fazemos amor pois
marcamos as férias
os homens que só voltará para os
ouvintes também é só páginas pois
fazemos amor outra coisa também é
importante salvar o caso
logo só se faça mas nem que seja uma
rapidinha todos sabemos que os homens
que fazer uma sou muito mais bem
dispostas e muito mais tranqüilo no
local de trabalho e hoje esse trabalho
no hospital em dois e quando manhã está
tudo mal humorado altman eo poema se
apoia tinha de entrada é verde quer
fazer sua vez de banhos mal amados
tudo bem é vilão ao tentar realizar o
estudo o emblema foi bem sport tudo
amanhã
quer dizer tão bem e matt cutts receita
consolidada é fundamental e nós temos de
ensinar as meninas também fazer uma
coisa de métrica volva e isso vai ser a
grande mudança da criatividade não só
treinar kaká mas também na vulva que
entrarem na vagina ea vulva e vagina tem
muitas rugas para estender de pós bebês
se a ideia é cuidar das rugas ainda
vagina vão pagar o nosso objetivo é
mantê los na vagina
por isso imagina que este é o ano
sistema ginestal os perdedores é filho
de 40 anos ea virgin mas jamais mas já
não é se esse implementada
vascularização que pois não tem dotes
ninguém é feliz maneira nenhuma com
dores conta a relações por isso
criatividade é fundamental é a pessoa
não pode ser
nós devemos ao contrário das muçulmanas
e das outras
andando música na rua e em casa com o
village green
nós andamos com liga mostrando rua em
casa quando cheguei que não sendo para
ir à rua não pode ser temos chegar a
casa e mantemos para surgiu para sair
nós fazemos um esquema que a região de
todas impecáveis tudo by é como ter um
cheirinho de chouriço e mostramos mas
não tocas por isso não os deixamos de
tocar a vida o que é uma pessoa te forma
e nomes deixado a abrir a porta do
frigorífico
a relação dos casais é principal causa
de votos e deixamos de fazer da moda é
sexualidade é a principal causa de voz
não só mas é muito importante as redes
sociais tohá tendo um aspecto verde
importante como todos sabemos 40% as
suas nos estados unidos solteiras que
andam namoro online e vamos pensar que
isso vai ainda aumentar mas depois é
capaz da rede
os pais só namorava acusavam seus
vizinhos da escola e com aquelas do
bairro hoje em dia como impede a
globalização bujones nós temos de
aprender alguma coisa não fazer só o
pilates e yoga e ia comer chineses
japoneses não a outras técnicas e outras
coisas sexualidade normal para cada um e
que nos levam fato é uma qualidade de
vida melhor investir na sexualidade com
criatividade com brinquedos um limite é
o infinito desde que as duas pessoas
estejam da coisa nós pode de maneira
nenhuma fazer coisas nos viola mas até
que ocaso vezes hoje não é muito
confortável
amanhã passa a ser todos os dias de
manhã teremos olha após pele e
sorridente estado vai conosco lopes não
podemos indicar o bebê estava o nosso a
ninguém
eu tenho meu próprio equilíbrio tem
tirar 30 minutos feliz todos os dias
moka fez impasse a 30 minutos e se
quiser pode se ouvir um passarinho
havido uma música mas tem um caderninho
onde eu todos os dias escreveu mostrando
também no traseiro e se eu chegar à casa
da gente disposta que é muito mais
agradável não vencendo sua vida para a
paz negativa não contar as coisas
negativas não pensar sempre uma coisa
negativa quando chegarmos a casa
se eu tiver um bom ambiente quando
alguém chega casa kelly ter comigo e o
software de no sino da privação quando o
prazer alguém e alcorta comigo
os viciados decorrem da kia a qualquer
lado a chover publicado o vice eu
produzi prazer energia outra pessoa é da
procura quando temos relações longa
duração afetividade constrói sempre
disso o amor não dependa do
relacionamento
o relacionamento esse fato mantém o amor
e é isso fundamental criar duas boas
seleções utilizar as redes sociais ea
tecnologia nos podem melhorar facto a
qualidade de vida mas nunca sequer ser
um abracinho e do beijinho que damos a
todos nós e uma boa tabela